hmm
sql
versus nosql
you'll be surprised to know that this
conversation comes up more than often
than you think hello my name is jamil
spain brand technical specialist with
the u.s financial services market
and as you try to pick a side on how you
want to choose to use sql or nosql
databases i thought it would be great
for me to bring out my top five
differences to really give you the
information you want to back up your
decision
so let's get started with this
when it comes to sql
we know that this works off a relational
database structure here
now that means that you're going to
access all your data points they have to
have some type of relation
you've got to do a lot of pre-work to
kind of decide out your structure how
they're going to relate whereas on the
nosql side this is not relational so we
really don't have to i really feel for a
lot of projects i can go ahead and get
started and deal with a lot of that
effort later on in the process here
as your database china checks uh gets a
lot of traffic
and needs to really start to grow
on the infrastructure for sql servers
they're going to vertically scale
okay whereas on the nosql side these are
going to be horizontal
scaling
all right um and we know that sql
servers are going to be backed by this
they're going to need more memory
more computing power to actually process
all these transactions whereas
horizontally with no sql it's all in
memory i can keep adding secondary nodes
to handle and balance out a lot of the
the usage there as well
on the sql side when i kind of talk
about my structure it's really going to
be always about table
being table based
i am super concerned about how i'm
categorizing my entities my my tables
into records and how i'm doing my
relationship so i have to kind of think
of a i like to say more of a warehouse
kind of nature that i'm collecting all
this data uh here as well and we all
know from nosql it is based on a
document approach
so these are really going to be
documents
all right they can be key value hashes
uh
this is great for graph ql i mean a lot
of the graphs okay it's really meant to
not really have
any kind of structure it's kind of the
opposite of being a table based i can
fit pretty much anything um in this as
well so what about when you want to
access all the data i'm going to have to
use the sql
query language to actually define all my
queries to pull all my data out so it's
kind of some pre-planning about how i'm
going to access and join my data if i'm
going to normalize all the data there
where i feel the nosql is definitely
much much more dynamic all right i'm
really able to um
really just
make my collections of these type of
documents no matter what the structure
and then i can have more freedom to let
it flow and how i want to query these
items as well
so lastly
sql great for multi
row
transactions
where we have our tables we have a lot
of data that we want to put in remember
the ability to do the transactions and
being able to roll back and forth so i
can really control a lot of what the
what goes in
on the other side with no sql we
remember that this is going to be all
unstructured
usually it's json it's very great for
working with daesan let me make sure i
write here on number four that was also
dynamic
all right so the unstructured json
versus something that
is a very planned out i specifically
want to enter
this in as well
so that kind of ends the features
between the two but actually i can think
of a scenario where this actually is
an and that should be here as well do we
really have to make a definitive choice
of either or
one of those scenarios goes to the fact
that i can have let's say i have a
common e-commerce application which is
usually composed of some bit of
mobile
um
and has some interaction with a more of
a back-end whether it's an api um that
wants to kind of go
we want to commit a lot of the data
think about a shopping cart okay let's
kind of visualize this for a minute as i
make sessions i browse
um i do all these things it's more like
data in transient it's not really ready
to be committed yet so i could see
unstructured session data product data
what i clicked on set of clicks all that
stuff could be great for compiling into
any structure into a nosql site and then
as i make the order or the transaction
that could be definitely something that
i kick off into my sql database back in
where i want to
facilitate interaction with different
departments not only is it going to the
shipping department maybe the marketing
maybe a couple other subsystems that i
want to document that order has been
placed and kick off a few other work
streams
so this is just one of many scenarios
that you can choose
i'll be curious to know uh in the future
whether you pick a side or you join
forces to power your next application
thank you for your time
if you have questions please drop us a
line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe